regarde un peu qui nous attendait bakou
a des ennuis
j'ai un petit problème elle s'appelait
lydia tu as fait venir de la can de
france dans le cadavre d'une fille
can't have 3,7 connaît depuis quand est
ce que ça me connaît une expérience
vegas miami et tout ça je suis un laveur
de scènes de crimes
microbes serpillière avec tout ça vous
avez vécu quoi tous les deux on veut
voir de quoi tu es capable
tu peux tout effacer c'est moi le
meilleur on fait pas dans le terminal
c'est pas notre truc je vois pas comment
je pourrais laisser un tel talent me
filer entre les doigts
il faut que tu fasses gars que tu te
prépares une sortie parce qu'à un moment
ça leur apprend on pense qu'il ya eu
l'avenir nous le dira spotless premier
épisode le 16 mars à 20h55 sur canal +
est exceptionnellement en diffusion
simultanée sur la chaîne youtube série
canal +